les élus du département réunis en
assemblée plénière ont voté une décision
modificative ayant pour conséquence des
ajustements sur le but il et 2016 la
réunion fait partie des dix départements
les plus endettés en france dans ce
contexte le financement du revenu de
solidarité active se fait de plus en
plus difficilement c'est pourquoi
l'assemblée des départements de france a
demandé au gouvernement de recentraliser
cette dépense l'état à titre
exceptionnel va nous aborder à peu près
une somme de 6 millions d'euros qui est
largement insuffisant par rapport à nos
besoins de financement ce qu'il faudrait
c'est à peu près de 40 millions d'euros
donc n'ayant plus les moyens de financer
totalement cette dépense nous à la
réunion mais d'autres départements en
métropole font la même chose nous avons
demandé à l'êta de recentraliser donc
cette dépense c'est ce que l'état est en
train de travailler sur ce dossier dont
on attend avec l'adf donc nous sommes
représentés par l'association des
départements de france
nous attendons donc les résultats de ces
travaux qui pour l'instant sont engagés
sur le principe même il y à un accord de
l'état pour que l'état de reprendre le
financement mais nous ne sommes pas
d'accord avec l'état sur les modalités
de cette reprise
pour la présidente du conseil
départemental nassimah dindar 2016 sera
l'année de la recentralisation des
compétences liées à la loi nôtre il faut
plus que jamais mutualiser les moyens
une année se termine et un autre chemin
est engagé nous allons dès l'année
prochaine
réunir région département des services
de l'état les communes les
intercommunalités la conférence des
financeurs pour se dire comment on va
travailler ensemble pour faire avancer
les projets du territoire et faire
avancer les dispositifs en faveur des
réunionnais et donc c'est vraiment une
étape
nouvelle un saut qualitatif que nous
aimerions non élus mettre en avant une
nouvelle dynamique pour que on ne fasse
plus de la politique les uns à côté des
autres mais véritablement que nous
mettions de la cohérence
institutionnelle de l'intelligence
institutionnels ensemble pour faire
avancer les dossiers regnault une
gestion de la collectivité qui passe
également par des propositions que
feront les conseillers départementaux
pour améliorer les dispositifs existants
et qui parfois peuvent devenir un
casse-tête administratif pour les
bénéficiaires à la conférence des
financeurs on va demander à ce qu'on
mette en place un dispositif
expérimental ici la loi prévoit que tous
les trois ans les handicapés ou gagnent
la hache mais tous les trois ans ou doit
refaire une demande pour à nouveau
l'agrément de la hache bacon les
handicapés reconnu irréversible et le
docteur il est battu par e mail à eau
dans la paperasse supplémentaire donc
nous on voudrait voté une délibération
qui permettent à la mdph de ne pas
remettre en place les cdaph obligatoire
la loi demande puisque les personnes
porteuses de handicap irréversible n'ont
plus besoin de faire de la paperasse et
et remplir les dossiers le conseil
départemental qui a également dit au
revoir à marco boyer et lui cède son
siège à son suppléant en hommage appuyé
lui était rendu
merci de m'avoir permis également de
mener cette campagne à tes côtés pour
saint benoît pour la plaine des
palmistes tuer une personne respectable
et respecté
les conseillers départementaux ont
rendez vous en mars de l'année prochaine
la première assemblée plénière de 2016
sera consacrée au vote du budget